in this project we're tackling
pathfinding a star optimization and just
getting a crapload of Units onto the
screen and moving around all at once
I ran across this cool video from
brackets who stressed tested the limits
of unities pass binding system was able
to get around 10,000 agents running
simultaneously and I wondered how many
could I get going in a single simulation
in JavaScript now I have a few things
working against me
unity is heavily optimized and I'm
working in JavaScript but I have a whole
bunch of ideas on what to do and I'm
granting myself permission to bend the
rules a bit so that if things aren't
doing things strictly correctly no big
deal in general path fighting is pretty
neat because it's pretty much at the
heart of any game AI you almost
certainly need a strong a-star
implementation I've never done much game
AI worked before so this is all pretty
new to me it was really a chance to
fiddle around with parts of the code
I've never done anything professionally
with a while back I already did a basic
a-star implementation which walks you
through the basics of the algorithm how
and why it works and how to implement it
today we're taking that a bit further so
let's mess around a bit concentrate on a
star optimization and see just how many
AI units I can have running around on a
reasonably complex map sound good like
always codes available check the
description below for kit do whatever
what we're gonna go over today is I'll
show you how I got from one little guy
wandering around the map to many little
guys wandering around the map so let's
start first we need a map now I can just
model it and blender but then I got to
do that every single time I want to try
out a bigger or smaller maze so that's
no good
luckily we happen to have one or at
least a way to get one since I already
wrote a maze generator using recursive
backtracking a little while ago the only
problem is that it's 2d no worries let's
just import the code and we'll screw
around a bit and turn it into a 3d mesh
here's where that magic happens on the
left you have the original two
map drawing code what this did was that
it traversed the graph looking at each
nodes neighbors and whether or not there
were edges between the nodes and then
drawing a line to represent a wall in
the 3d version you traverse the graph
looking at each node neighbors and
whether or not there are any edges
between the nodes and then you create a
rectangle
afterwards when this is all done we
merge them into one massive static mesh
and add some ground underneath now we
don't want strictly a maze since that's
typically one entrance one the exit type
of deal so afterwards we'll go over the
maze and make a whole bunch of openings
everywhere making it easier to find
multiple paths from the top to the
bottom is this the most efficient
solution ever conceived not really but
it works and it's fine so let's just
move on so we have a map next we have to
make a unit move and luckily again I
implemented Boyd's a while back voids is
just a term for a loose collection of
steering behaviors that you can apply to
an individual agent or Boyd I'm gonna
repurpose that code but strip out all
but one of the behaviors the seek
behavior will keep that one and will add
a path following behavior which is given
a list of nodes representing the path
and the Boyd will seek from one node to
the next following that path and that'll
give us a working path following a a guy
see watch and walk along and no matter
how complex the past this little guy
will find a path through and then
navigate the paths were these alright so
we're all set up we have some
procedurally generated mazes we have an
AI agent navigating the maze now let's
make this fast first we need to do some
ace tower optimization work to improve
performance I already covered a basic
a-star implementation going over the
core of the algorithm and its
implementation how and why it works and
how the heuristic guides the expansion
of nodes that basic implementation works
but there's some room for improvement
the first thing I did was create a
separation between a running instance of
an a-star search and appending one so we
create this a-star management class that
creates proxy clients the job of the
a-star client is to serve as a thin
client between the manager and AI agents
that need a search to be performed what
they do is wait for the manager to pass
them a running instance of a star and
clients can check if their search is
pending active or finished and get to
build paths all this serves to gate the
number of running instances of a star
since if we have say 10,000 AI agents
running through the scene we don't want
to try and run 10,000 instances of a
star all at once
next I tweak the heuristic normally when
you're shown how to do a star it's with
the distance to goal function or what's
called an admissible heuristic I'm
changing this over to use Manhattan
distance since this is a grid and
Manhattan distance is more correct and
also cheaper to perform I've also made a
very slight change here and added a
multiplier on the heuristic this means
that the heuristic we're using is no
longer admissible but this has the
effect of making a star run in fewer
steps the trade-off is that the paths it
chooses are no longer guaranteed to be
optimal
but that's fine for our purpose now
that's all enabled looks like I can bump
this up to around 4,000 units or so
before the frame rate begins to drop
here there are 4,000 separate units all
doing path bindings through a fairly
massive scene and we're comfortably
running at 30 fps
there are still more a-star optimization
ideas and tricks I could try out but at
this point will render bound due to the
enormous number of meshes so let's fix
that what we're going to do now is move
our meshes over to use instancing which
is just a way of drawing large batches
of the same object quickly what it does
is reduces the number of draw calls and
thus material changes and that stuff
that the API and driver need to handle
that's reducing the overall CPU usage
you can see the second we switched to
instancing we can bump up our agent
count and it looks like we can now
support around 15,000 AI agents or so
wandering around through the maze at a
comfortable 30fps bumping it up much
beyond that tanks the frame rate so
we're gonna have to try and fix other
things now taking a quick profile using
dev tools a few easy things pop out
we're spending a lot of time updating
the matrix and we're also encouraged
some garbage collections from JavaScript
most likely due to allocations let's go
and fix those managing the world matrix
ourselves instead of having
we gs2 it and pre allocating some
vectors and matrices to work with and
suddenly our framerate shoots up even
higher
here's 60,000 and still at a comfortable
30fps which is pretty good they're all
navigating the mesh independently and
doing a full a-star search for their
path so there's no pre-computation of
paths or anything of that sort no funny
stuff here and that's where we'll end
this this was really just for fun and
kind of screwing around maybe you can
use some of the ideas in your own
projects in the future who knows I'm
pretty sure I can get into the hundreds
of thousands but that'll require some
more work and planning move things into
other threads or even push work onto the
GPU
I've got some ideas and if I decide to
act on them I'll make a video about it
thanks for watching everyone I hope you
learned something remember to hit like
and subscribe and also comment and let
me know what you thought
until next time cheers everyone
you